ils ont fait barrage de leur corps
pendant 40 minutes hier soir c'est
militants bloque le pont Sèvres
au-dessus de la scène un axe très
fréquenté
hier soir les voitures sur le pont de
Sèvres quand d'autres gugusse entrent
dans le dans les musées l'un pour se
coller le front à un tableau l'autre
pour vandaliser une toile historique
vous croyez que ça m'amuse
[Musique]
ça va rien changer ce que vous faites
bien sûr que ça changera rien toujours
aucune prise de parole du président
d'extrême droite Jr bolsonaro après sa
défaite face à Lula elles son fils s'est
exprimée sur les réseaux sociaux
n'abandonnons pas notre Brésil a-t-il
écrit alors que de nombreuses routes
vous le voyez sont bloquées notamment
par des groupes de camionneurs
promotionnaro dernier jour le collectif
dernier rénovation à multiplié ce genre
d'action avec un blocage de l'autoroute
A6 vendredi ou ce militant venu
interrompre un spectacle sur la scène de
l'Opéra Bastille sous les huées du
public
[Applaudissements]
il a fallu 2000 ans pour se mettre
d'accord sur ce que c'était que le crime
organisé à la convention de Palerme pour
le terrorisme on en est très très loin
parce qu'il y a rien qui ressemble plus
à résistant qu'un terroriste on est
toujours le terroriste de quelqu'un
d'autre et le seul élément qu'on
pourrait prendre comme élément de
définition c'est l'atteinte à la vie
humaine de quelqu'un qui n'a aucun moyen
de régler votre problème dans ce premier
novembre quelque changement à noter
d'abord c'est le fin le début de la
trêve hivernale les expulsions de
domicile ne sont plus possibles jusqu'au
31 mars prochain ah bonjour Comment ça
va président félicitations
[Musique]
nous vivons une journée très heureuse
parce que nous avons pu récupérer la
démocratie dans notre pays
revalorisation aussi de 50% de la
pension alimentaire minimale pour
soutenir les mères célibataires enfin
l'obligation d'avoir des pneus hiver
jusqu'au 31 mars pour les automobilistes
roulant dans les zones de montagne
j'attendais avec beaucoup d'impatience
ce moment pour qu'on puisse relancer un
partenariat stratégique à la hauteur de
notre histoire et des défis qui sont
devant nous merci à toi et félicitations
pour cette élection le Conseil d'État en
effet juge a dit la règle a dit que il
fallait revenir un contrôle technique
donc il faudra très probablement on est
en train de regarder cette décision il
faudra très probablement mettre en place
un contrôle technique sache que donne
madame Rousseau d'elle-même et ça ça va
être intéressant d'ailleurs de voir à
une prochaine élection et bien sûr on la
connaît mais est-ce qu'on la connaît
positivement quelque chose qui soit le
moins pénalisant possible parce que moi
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de motards je
suis pas motard moi-même chacun détaché
à la sécurité à la qualité de son
véhicule et donc je crois qu'il faut
qu'on soit raisonnable et
proportionnelle dans les coulisses une
femme extrêmement sympathique beaucoup
plus nuancée évidemment que l'image
qu'elle donne et relativement
intelligente et plutôt cultivée
l'industrie pétrolière n'a pas tenu son
engagement d'investir en Amérique
une par une les grandes compagnies
pétrolières ont enregistré des bénéfices
record mais ce n'est pas seulement juste
retour d'un travail acharné leur
bénéfice sont si élevés que c'est
difficile à croire elle s'est inventée
un personnage et que je crois que ce
personnage un jour va la tuer c'est
qu'elle va être burn out c'est-à-dire
que là elle vit un quart d'heure ou à
relier à travers ce personnage tient une
sorte de célébrité monumentale mais ça
va lui revenir en mouvement et cette
femme d'un jour faire une dépression
absolument tragique les bénéfices
records d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas dû au
fait qu'elles font quelque chose de
nouveau ou d'innovant leur profits sont
une manne de guerre c'est une des
conséquences de la flambée des prix de
l'énergie l'entreprise Duralex ferme ses
portes à partir d'aujourd'hui et
jusqu'au mois d'avril la fameuse verérie
près de d'Orléans a vu ses factures
multipliées par 5 en 1 an les 250
salariés sont en chômage partiel et
c'est salarié fuient leur usine valise à
la main les plus chauds seront pu
embarquer dans des camions en plein banc
il voyage à plusieurs sur la plateforme
arrière
cette femme elle n'a pas hésité à
s'accrocher à un camion-citerne quand le
parc a fermé hier il y avait encore des
milliers de visiteurs à l'intérieur
résultat pas de parade pas de feu
d'artifice pas de manège mais une
nouvelle attraction le test covid parce
que pour pouvoir sortir du parc tous les
visiteurs devaient se faire tester et
ressortir avec un test négatif la tente
a duré plus de 10 heures pour partir
c'est travailleurs ont dû escalader le
grillage après plusieurs cas de covid
mi-octobre l'entreprise a confiné les
lieux interdisant à quiconque de sortir